I'm Cory Bernatt, and I
run the business called
First Aid for Leather by
Sandalman in Toronto, Canada.
I'm going to be taking you
through a restoration process
of a 70-year-old horsehide leather jacket.
I believe the jacket was worth
about $100 70 years ago,
and it's probably worth
about $1,500 today.
It would probably be about
a $1,500 restoration.
This is a jacket that was
made out of horsehide,
which in the past was something
that was quite common.
Nowadays, most leather jackets of its type
are reproductions made out of cowhide,
which is not as strong as horsehide.
It's basically broken
down on every aspect.
The knit cuffs and waistband.
The leather's completely
deteriorated over time,
as you can see, the fading and drying out.
The collar, which is made from sheepskin,
has started to bald and lose hair.
The first thing we have to
do is take everything apart.
Part of the treatment process
is just washing down the
surface of the leather
with a pH-balanced soap,
which is noninvasive.
It helps to keep the original colors
without stripping any of the
pigment from the leather.
I'm removing the knit cuff and waistband
from the jacket by using a seam ripper
to take it off from the
edge of where it was sewn.
In the case of the knit cuffs,
it goes around in a circle,
so you basically just pick
an area, start with that,
and then just go around
till you get to the end.
If we're going with the zipper,
we would go and start at the top
and then move down to the bottom.
We do this along all the edges
where the material is
attached to the leather.
Then the lining had to be disassembled.
Once the lining is disassembled,
then we have to break it into its parts.
Once we've disassembled the entire jacket,
we have to then repattern
by using the original design,
because we have to make
sure that everything
fits back together in exactly the same way
as it was made in the first place.
The original collar was
made out of sheepskin.
It is starting to show signs
of what I call balding.
After so many years of use,
you'll find that the
hair starts to disengage
from the base material.
The first thing that we do is
we disassemble it from
the original collar,
and then we flatten it
out to allow us to get
an accurate reading on the measurements.
And then that gets cut out,
so that way we have all of the proper
seam allowances to allow
for the stitch to go on.
I've chosen to modernize this design
rather than trying to restore
it back to its original.
It gives more contrast
to the brown leather
by using the black trim.
The fabric on the zipper is black,
the knit's in black, as
well as the internal lining
is made from a quilted
lining made out of black.
So everything has a
consistency amongst the jacket.
Once I take the internal
lining out of the jacket,
we break it into its various parts.
Everything is pressed with an iron
to make sure that everything lies flat,
and then we make sure that we have
enough lining material
when we're cutting it,
because if we don't do this properly
then it'll end up being short.
When I'm rebuilding a lining for a jacket,
it has no pockets.
It's just a flat piece of material.
We then have to create the pocket.
In this case, we created
a leather-trimmed pocket.
We have to cut the leather pieces
that are going to be
incorporated into the pocket,
and it has to be cut and sewn
in such a way that when it's completed,
it is a finished pocket.
The cuff is made from a combination
of cotton and polyester and elastic.
So it's woven together so
that it has a nice soft feel
and at the same time it has
a little bit of elasticity
so that it holds on your
wrist and on your waistband
and keeps the air out.
When we're making measurements,
we want to make sure
that we make marks on it
that are not invasive to the material
that can easily be wiped off.
I like using a chalkboard char.
It easily comes off.
That allows us to get accurate patterning
and then wipe it off later
so it doesn't leave a mark.
Once we cut the materials,
we then have to reassemble everything
back to the original design.
The toughest part about
reconstructing a jacket like this
is just making sure that
everything fits together
exactly as it had begun.
We do this one step at a time
with each individual aspect of the jacket.
The cuffs have to be
turned inside out and sewn
and then folded over so that it creates
the double layer.
All of the linings have
to be sewn back together.
We make notches at various
points of the lining
so that we know as we're sewing
that we're sewing it to the right point,
so that where the shoulder
starts and the side begins,
that each of those points
are matched in the right way.
The waistband has to be put in
before the lining is attached,
because the lining will
then cover up the knit.
The knit gets sandwiched
between the leather and the lining,
so that way if you were
to turn it inside out
you'd see a nice clean finish.
I've kind of coined the phrase
"reconditioning leather."
We do a conditioning treatment
with the liquid oil for a week,
and then at the end of that process
we then move on to the thicker oil.
So we're getting a two-week treatment
with two different oils
with only a couple of
days' break in between.
After 70 years of use,
all of the initial essential oils
that were part of the
leather have all evaporated.
What I do when I'm treating the leather
is I'm putting back some
of those essential oils.
You'll notice also the flexibility
of the leather increases,
because once the oils get
introduced to the leather,
everything starts to soften up.
All of the fibers inside the leather,
everything becomes healthier,
darker, more supple.